[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
auf das heutige video haben sehr sehr
viele von euch gewartet denn heute ist
es endlich soweit ich habe toffees
selber gemacht und zwar seht ihr hier
jetzt denke ich wo sind denn deine
toffifee hier sind meine und hier die
originalen und ich finde optisches nicht
machen ganz großer unterschied bei mir
ist einfach die karamell schichten ein
bisschen dunkler auch ein bisschen
dicker und geschmacklich sind wirklich
sehr lecker ich zeige euch heute wie man
karamell selbst erstellt wie man daraus
auch leckere weine karamellbonbons
machen kann wie ich sie dann befüllen
und am ende fertig stellen und natürlich
gibt es am ende die große
geschmacksprobe also starten wir jetzt
direkt mit dem parlament und ich zeige
euch hier vorne mal die zutaten für das
karamell brauche ich 200 gramm sahne 400
gramm zucker 200 gramm hellen serie eine
prise salz und 50 gramm kalte butter
chef nehme ich jetzt die sahne die kommt
jetzt hier in einen kleinen topf und die
lasse ich jetzt einmal kurz aufkochen
und stellt dann den herd wieder aus und
in einem anderen topf kann ich jetzt das
karamell herstellen dafür nehme ich
jetzt den helm sirup und den habe ich
jetzt einfach im supermarkt gefunden der
städte nehmen honig marmelade und es
lockert aufstrichen und da findet ihr
einfach den hellen sirup manchmal gibt
es auch karamell sirup den könnt ihr
auch nehmen dann hat er nämlich schon
mal den karam and geschmack und den
braucht ihr auf jeden fall
es ist einfacher mit vier um zu arbeiten
und mit zucker damit späteres karamell
einfach nicht so kristallisiert
jetzt kommt hier das zucker noch mit
rein
und jetzt so ein bisschen verbinden
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt noch das salz mit
dazu das salz hilft dabei später den
karamell geschmack ein bisschen
hervorzuheben jetzt schalte ich hier den
herd an auf mittel hohe hitze und wer
das ganze jetzt erstmal aufkochen lassen
und dann benutze ich gleich ein zucker
thermometer aber ich sage ich auch
gleich wieder das ganze ohne zucker
thermometer herstellen können
[Musik]
das karamell koch sitzt gerade auf und
ab und zu kann es passieren dass die
zuckerkristalle am topf wand kleben
bleiben
dann nehmt ihr einfach an den pinsel und
etwas wasser und können dann mit hilfe
des pinsels die zuckerkristalle so ein
bisschen runterschrauben das karamell
muss jetzt auch gar nicht durchgeführt
werden und ich nehme es dass zucker
thermometer und kontrolliere einfach ab
und so die temperatur
es soll auf etwa 120 grad kommen
[Musik]
das karamell hat jetzt die perfekte
temperatur und ohne thermometer seht ihr
dann dass es eine schöne karamell farbe
bekommt und dass diese bläschen einfach
immer kleiner werden das heißt man
müsste einfach drauf achten und jetzt
nämlich das thermometer kurz raus und
kann nicht die sahne zufügen und daher
ist es auch wichtig dass wir die sahne
vorher kurz aufkochen lassen damit er
einfach nicht zu kalt ist ansonsten
entsteht nämlich in dicker fetter
zuckerbrot
[Musik]
satz karamell und einkochen lassen jetzt
140 grad celsius das heißt hier steht
jetzt auf dem thermometer soft dreck und
jetzt ist es perfekt ich habe gerade
eben eine probe gemacht und zwar habe
ich wieder ein stückchen auf einen
teller gegeben das ganze auch etwas
gefrorenes gestellt so jetzt einfach
schneller fest und jetzt seht dass ich
auch richtig schön fest obwohl es noch
was kann ich vorsichtig die thermometer
wegnehmen und alles was jetzt übrigens
mit karamell in verbindung kam bekommt
ihr ganz leicht mit wasser sauber zucker
ist ja wasserlöslich das heißt gibt es
einfach in einen topf zurück laster
wasser drin aufkochen und später wird
einfach alles ganz schnell sauer
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier die kalte butter mit
rein die hatte ich gerade auch bis eben
im kühlschrank und die mädels eingerührt
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich hier zwei eiswürfel
formen und zwar sind die aus silikon
vielleicht fragt ihr euch jetzt auch ob
man die leere im topspiel verpackungen
nehmen kann
die kann man auf keinen fall nehmen
dennis karamell ist einfach viel zu heiß
und die form wird einfach schmelzen
deswegen auf jeden fall eiswürfel
behälter die werde ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen fetten so bekomme ich die
bonbons später ein bisschen einfacher
raus und jetzt arbeitet wirklich ganz
ganz vorsichtig das sieht zwar nicht
heiß aus aber karamell ist ganz ganz
furchtbar heiß ich hab ich heute zweimal
verbrannt wurde auch ziemlich weh und
jetzt fühle ich die formen jeweils bis
zur hälfte
[Musik]
drei förmchen habe ich jetzt gefüllt die
werde ich jetzt ganz kurz ruhen lassen
damit sie etwas abkühlen und ich dann
eine mulde reinform kann
jetzt habe ich noch ein bisschen was
übrig daraus werde ich weiß ich fahre
mit bonbons machen dafür nehme ich jetzt
eine kasko und licht alkohol hier aus
und zwar mit der matten seite nach oben
also die glänzenden seite nach oben
[Musik]
die alufolie fertig jetzt mit etwas back
trance prey und fühle dann der masse ein
und kann sich so abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt ist das ganze etwas abgekühlt habe
aber mit dem finger geschaut aber im
krieg ist ein paar minuten warten und
dürft euch nicht verbrennen jetzt könnt
ihr entweder ein werkzeug nehmen einem
board von beispiel und drückt dann so
ein bisschen rein und formt sozusagen
eine mulde hinein oder ihr nehmt einfach
die finger und streicht das karamell das
abgekühlte karamell ein bisschen nach
oben
[Musik]
die fans sind jetzt fertig da dürft ihr
auch nicht zu lange warten denn das
karamell wird ja auch fest und ihr fest
es wird umso schwieriger wir jetzt auch
das ganze zu formen
die sind jetzt mittlerweile auch schon
abgekühlt das heißt bis das letzte
fertig geformt war waren die ersten
schon habt jetzt kann ich euch noch
zeigen was ich zum fertig stellen
brauchen zum fertig stellen brauche ich
jetzt ein paar ganze haselnüsse hier
habe ich lukas also nuss nougat und hier
habe ich noch 100 gramm kupfer türen
gibt es nämlich den nougat und zwar
nehme ich da am liebsten wenn fieber low
carb den habe ich mal auf einer messe
auf der esm kennengelernt und der
schrecklich sehr lecker schmeckt richtig
muss ich und auch sehr zart schmelzend
der pasta jetzt perfekt rein ist öffne
ich dem unternehmen jetzt erstmal nur
eine stange
das sind 50 gramm und ich schaue dann
einfach wie ich zurechtkomme und die
stange gebe ich jetzt in einen
gefrierbeutel drücken jetzt eigentlich
im herzen sie am liebsten wirklich sagen
jetzt essen und verschließt den beutel
und hängt das ganze dann in heiß ist und
nicht mehr kochendes wasser und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich hier vor die
förmchen befüllt und nehmen jetzt
einfach jeweils eine haselnuss von
gibson mit hier rein
[Musik]
jetzt ist er nur gott weiß schon jetzt
kann ich hier vorne eine kleine spitze
abschneiden und den beutel sozusagen als
spritzbeutel benutzen und jetzt befehle
ich die förmchen und ein bisschen luca
darf auch über das karamell überstehen
[Musik]
als ich brauche mindestens noch 20 grad
stange und zum verteilen des no ganz
einfach form ein bisschen klopfen und
dann wird sein platz
[Musik]
der lukas abgekühlt und ich habe
erzählte kurator bereits klein gehackt
und die bei einem warmen aber nicht mehr
kochen ein wasserbad erwärmt und das
ganze mit der mitschnitt wurde das heißt
zuerst zwei drittel kuvertüre
geschmolzen
dann vom wasserbad heruntergenommen und
das restliche drittel eingerührt
so hat die perfekte temperatur und
bekommt später keinen grauschleier und
jetzt fühle ich die schokolade einfach
wieder in einen gefrierbeutel ich
arbeite normalerweise lieber mit
spritzbeutel aber gefrierbeutel hat
jeder zu hause da zeige ich das einfach
so jetzt wird eine spitze wieder weg
geschnitten und dann kommt jemand ein
klecks direkt auf die toffees mit ich
drauf
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles abgefüllt ich zeige euch
jetzt zuerst einmal luftig
karamellbonbons nein nein nein nein
minute warten neun jahren ja wohl hier
löst sich richtig einfach nicht können
sie auch gerne zwei drei läuferinnen mit
seinem wegschmeißen
jetzt werde ich meinen messer ein
bisschen fetten sonst kann die
karamellbonbons durchschneiden und daran
seht ihr jetzt auch dass es richtig
schön weich ist vielleicht mal probieren
muss terra x bow wow die schneide ich
später noch zu aber dadurch dass sie
kleben sieht man dass sie es besser
machen können immer kürzer mag ihn
zunächst und die auszeichnung des
papiers zuckertüte machen und aus
zeitungspapier aber du kannst aus
pergamentpapier aus der kernstadt hier
stehen eigentlich die kohleunternehmen
so karamellbonbons zu verschenken
den meisten gelingt einfach nicht weiter
karamellbonbons worden und ist
deutschlandweit zahnabdruck ich sowieso
so schön weiß weiß ich auch richtig gut
aber ich stelle jetzt zur seite dass es
nämlich nur ein tolles nebenprodukt
heute jetzt soll es um die tafel geben
diese verstehen sind übrigens richtig
gut weil sie hier unten im silicon
beschichtung haben das heißt ja ohnehin
sehr weich und man kann das ganz einfach
ausdrücken
oliver morath oder ausprobieren oder
standen gerade zu lange draußen momentan
bei uns ist gerade sehr sehr heiß
deswegen hatte ich die auch im
kühlschrank alle noch mal
fertige stop gewähr hier ist ein low
carb auch schön fest schokolade ist fest
ich calle drehen und die richtig coolen
karamell hat immer nur ein nachteil man
mit ihm und 19
geschmacklich aber echt genial jetzt
zeige ich einmal ein original hier
ich find meinen toffifee bei den
originalen da ist das hier einfach diese
typische musterung hier das original und
hier bis getötet
das nachgemacht von silly oder ich finde
optisch jedes gar nicht was ein großer
und gesang ist ein bisschen dunkler ist
ein dunklen genau dass novartis bis zur
dunkelheit das karamell auch aber
ansonsten bin ich genauso vom geschmack
her finde ich einfach da muss man
ehrlich sein es ist anders er es
schmeckt jetzt nicht besser es schmeckt
jetzt auch nicht schlechter weg mal
anders schmeckt man einfach anders genau
das ist ja und ich denke man so wie wir
nicht selber nachmachen um ist ein
billiger zu machen ja als würdiger oder
besser zu machen ich finde eigentlich
nur das rezept ganz sinnvoll um mal zu
wissen wie das hergestellt wird man weiß
einfach es ist ein ziemlich aufwendiger
prozess vor allem die karamell
herstellung ist ziemlich schwierig und
ich empfehle euch da auf jeden fall das
arbeiten mit dem thermometer
ansonsten kann es einfach sein dass es
noch zu flüssig oder zu fest ist und
dann schmeckt einfach nicht so gut genau
mit deutsche forschung gesagt man kann
kaum mehr laufen fertig kaufen gehen
raus und fertigprodukten fertigprodukt
zu machen ist natürlich auch so eine
sache
ich hoffe dass euch dieses rezept
gefallen hat und wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen gerne dürfte mir in
die kommentare schreiben was ich als
nächstes nach machen soll
bei mir auf meiner liste steht auf jeden
fall soft cache mit drauf also diese
kleinen feinen kuchen
wieso greift zum original ja das muss an
das original auch schon die kleinen
feinen soft facts die möchte ich gerne
mal machen und andere wünschen nämlich
auch gerne
die beschleunigten mal meldet sich auch
noch genau ich auch cool hier bekommt
man halt die karamell schlecht bis dahin
beim original weil es eben industriell
hergestellt ist lukas schust verletzt
nein ich habe die gar nicht gestört
hast du einen garten machs gut bei uns
steckt
[Musik]